but nice and modern and a short
German video because it's also about a
German video what I'm announcing
something unusual tomorrow morning in
February 20th that's Shrove Monday
a roller Shrove Monday I'm doing a
live show 9 o'clock in the morning is like I said
yes how did it happen tomorrow  it's
6 years anniversary
six years of check24 or test
rallye form and then the
all-day school is coming so you don't go to the normal
show in the evening and i
'm just fine then i'll just do
nine o'clock in the morning for those who don't like
carnivals so tomorrow morning at 9 at just
if you look before you can find me
there i will link it again
but if he goes to the
page choose the find okay if you have time and
want time tomorrow morning 9
tune in